hello it's four o'clock this is an ass
sky news easing the lockdown
special as england prepares to loosen
restrictions this weekend
coming up in the next 60 minutes two
meters
becomes one a social distancing rules
are reduced
pubs and restaurants prepare to open
their doors as revelers get ready for
super saturday and a trim at last
barbers and hairdressers get ready to
tackle those lock down locks
for the first time in three months
[Music]
good afternoon after more than three
months of lockdown some aspects of life
in england will return to some semblance
of normality tomorrow
but there is still some confusion about
the new rules and why they are being
brought in now
at five o'clock this evening the prime
minister boris johnson will attempt to
explain all as he hosts a news briefing
at downing street
over the next hour i'm going to be
speaking to a panel of experts from the
world of science
medicine and business to answer your
questions first
let's look at what is and isn't changing
tomorrow
our correspondent adele robinson has the
details
so from tomorrow the two metre social
distancing rule will be replaced with a
one
meter plus measure where two meters
isn't possible
and in addition to that there'll be
recommended safety measures such as
face coverings increased hygiene and
changes to business layouts social
gatherings will also be different as
two households will be able to meet
regardless
of size indoors and outdoors so
things for example like dinner parties
will be allowed and overnight stays as
well
a long list of businesses will reopen
including restaurants
pubs and cafes but safety measures will
mean
minimal staff and customer contact table
service
and taking customers contact details to
help with any tracing
in case of an outbreak the tourism
industry gets a welcome boost
too as hotels b b's holiday homes
and campsites open their doors with
extra measures in place
to keep shared facilities clean and safe
and there'll be plenty of cultural and
leisure options available
with the return of indoor venues such as
museums
galleries cinemas amusement arcades and
even
fun fairs playgrounds libraries and
community centers have also got the
green light as have hairdressers where
staff
will have to wear visors places of
worship will also be able to reopen
again
for prayers and services such as
weddings which will see
a 30 person limit so what remains
closed well quite a long list nightclubs
indoor gyms
nail bars spas bowling alleys
indoor swimming pools as well and water
parks will all have to wait a little bit
longer before they're allowed to reopen
thanks adele well in a moment we'll get
some answers to all your questions
joining me we have oxana pisik from the
university of london school of pharmacy
we've also got patricia yates
from visit britain we've got charlotte
mensah from
a hair salon owner joining us also and
also sean tipton there at the end
joining us from avatar to answer all
your travel questions
but just before we get started let's get
a quick word from our deputy political
editor sam coats as we look ahead to
boris johnson's news briefing in an
hour's time
um sam the prime minister said that
today uh the uk is very much
through the worst of the coronavirus
pandemic but
warned people not to blow it it seems
that that he's saying yes go out but but
use your common sense and caution
yes boris johnson wants to be the face
of lifting the lock down in england at
least for the area that he's responsible
for
uh when it comes to the regulations that
change tomorrow
but he also wants to deliver a slightly
more nuanced and cautious message not
least because there are
as the latest data shows some areas
where the r value
uh is quite possibly above one and that
includes
uh london which means that the
coronavirus pandemic isn't shrinking
necessarily in the capital so the uh
job of him today is to set out that
whilst he is delighted clearly that
restaurants and pubs and
other social venues can reopen with the
ending of the two meter rule
he's also going to stress that the
success of these businesses
and the livelihoods that rely on them do
depend on everybody doing their part
and continuing to observe those rules
that remain and the guidance
which in many cases becomes voluntary uh
rather than
uh legal uh so boris johnson wanting to
be there
as the country uh starts to come out of
lockdown northern ireland of course
uh roamed its pubs today uh scotland uh
next week
uh but also to deliver a cautious
message to urge people
uh not to get carried away uh with the
freedoms that they'll get from midnight
sam thanks very much for that right
let's get started on your questions lots
of you've been sending them in to
hashtag ask sky news
let's start with the most important
thing for a lot of people uh charlotte
mensah hair salon owner
and how is it going to be different now
for people coming in and getting their
hair cut
oh it's gonna be very different because
um
now clients can only come in um
one by one likes only at their
appointment time
and there's no more waiting area we have
no magazines
no luxury of tea or coffee and
also um they all have to wear like
gloves and
masks and all our team we're all going
to be wearing our mask and vices as well
so it's going to be very different no
chatting it's going to be very very
different to what we're used to
and the one meter plus rule i mean
you're not going to be able to do that
and cut someone's hair are you is it
is it just going to be a matter of that
one person who's dealing with the
customer
will be able to touch them yeah so
there's going to be
um all our staff is going to be on
rotation there's so there's going to be
just
um a few of us working at any one
particular time
so it will be much less work we're going
to open
more longer hours and more days because
we're doing less work so
it's going to be very different the fact
that you can't even have that chat
because you've got the mask on
is going to make it so different to what
we're normally used to
people are going to be so relieved i
think me included
let's move on to patricia from visit
britain patricia
what are going to be the big popular
destinations tomorrow that haven't been
open so far do you think
well i i think pubs i mean i've booked
in my local pub
it'll be quite a different experience so
no no walking in
and just buying a drink you need to have
books you need to sit at a table you
need to order food
so i think a bit of pre-planning needed
if you're thinking of going to places
tomorrow
um and and of course if the weather's
nice i'm sure people want to go to the
beaches and go to beachside
cafes and restaurants as well but one
important question that quite a lot of
people have wanted to know about is lose
uh where will there be lavatories are
they all now going to be reopening
do you know i've heard uh it said that
never have so many senior people been
sitting around talking about toilets
um very important so there is now but
there is now a website um called
lockdown lose
that's been started up that that sort of
crowd crowd sourced
so if you know it's open around your
area put it on there but it's a really
good place to start
um local authorities and destinations
and looking at opening their toilets
we know so that some of the outdoor
parks like your gardens have
have pioneered opening toilets and
managed to do it and i
and i absolutely appreciate a really
important point for people
brilliant it certainly is um now
traveling a little bit further
sean let's bring you in for from abda
and bill has tweeted
will there be testing for temperatures
when you go to airports now
it will depend on the country you're
visiting um certainly when you're
leaving the uk no you won't
but in countries such as spain yes you
will so it's a very picture it really is
i mean what the reason why travel is
opening up at the moment is because the
the level of infection in many
destinations has come down drastically
they've suffered quite a lot in terms of
those as of us obviously in the uk in
terms of the economic impact of this
and they want to open up but they want
to do it in a safe way
so you will have your temperature tested
in certain destinations and if it is
over a certain height you might
actually be quarantining at that point
but the countries have said if that has
to happen
most they will pay for that themselves
so so it's a mixed picture really but i
think the main point is this
that if you have a high temperature then
i think really
very serious about whether you should be
getting on that flight in the first
place
uh another uh message in to us an email
when will the fast-track passport
services reopen i guess the people who
have got those
uh luxuries might not necessarily want
to stand with the hoi polloi with the
rest of us
exactly yeah i just prefer most people
on fast track is because they've
realized that
very just very close to their day to
travel that their passport needs
renewing oh they're going to lose their
holidays so
it's not cheap fast track it costs a lot
more money but the reason why it's shut
at the moment
is that you physically have to attend an
interview now you can see
for obvious reasons that's not something
that they'll be very keen on doing so
i'm not quite sure when it's going to
open up again
but uh applying for a password renewing
a password online is a very
straightforward process
it doesn't take very long it's taking a
bit longer than normal to be fair but it
doesn't take that long
and also you can go into many post
offices and they run a service in
conjunction with the passport office
there's a little fee for it but they'll
check to make sure that the application
has been done properly
and at that point it will be posted off
by them to the password office
and they pretty much rubber stamp though
so i generally speaking as i said don't
leave it to the last minute it's never a
good idea because you ate it cost a lot
of money and b
you sometimes have to worry about
whether that's going to come through in
time
so but usually usually it takes about 45
days for a passport to be
actually processed it's not going to be
quite that quick now but i'd say if
you're coming up for renewal
don't leave it too late don't hang about
yeah good advice and oksana pizzic from
university college and
andy has tweeted in he says you know we
were just talking to charlotte there why
is it safe for hair salons to open
but not to two parlors
sorry what type of perlers tattoo
parlors
and so of course the uh nature of the
activity involved and the type of
contact
um is much closer than it would be
um even with a hairdresser or in the
salon
um because of the uh making the ink
imprint in the skin
and all of those um more serious measure
than than what a haircut
involves um so for that reason
um it is safer for people to get
haircuts
okay and um coming back to hair
um charlotte is is it better for you to
wear a visor
or a mask when you're when you're going
to be doing this how difficult is it
going to be
doing your job now i think with
it's something that we're all gonna have
to learn to
to to just deal with because it's just a
much lower risk of the
um infection spreading and also
um you know when you're doing hair
you're so close and
around the person as well so it's good
that you've got the visor
and the mask on so that way there's
you know very very little risk and
it's safer for the um client as as well
as the
the stylist so it's really important
that we do wear
the mask and the visors and and of
course these things all cost
um i know that i've managed to get a
hair report and booked in the next two
weeks three weeks actually
but i know it's gone up they're saying
that they're adding a ppe charge are you
doing that as well
almost salons doing that yeah we're
adding
um an additional cost because we've had
to buy
so much like disposable gowns towels
that
you know so much um mask as well and
gloves for the customers just in case
they didn't bring their own
and also we've had to put so much like
partitions
between the seats and the sink so that
also
has cost a lot of money so we're going
to have to add that on
hopefully it wouldn't cost too much for
the customer because um
they're so excited to be coming back and
we want them to
to continue to come back so hopefully it
shouldn't be
too much okay patricia yates from visit
britain uh
what about outdoor shows we know that
the large gatherings of people inside
are certainly not being uh encouraged or
allowed but what about some of the large
outdoor maybe agricultural shows are
they likely to go ahead this autumn this
summer
um they're certainly not going ahead at
the moment and one of the big questions
the industry has is that those big
conferences trade fairs business events
still don't have a start date
so um i see there's a big increase in
driving cinema
so you can do things like that but but
no there isn't a date for
big gatherings to start yet and you
talked
a little earlier about being excited
about going to the pub use as a family
but but what are the other
do you think big family destinations
that people uh
will be wanting to go to we've we've got
pubs we've got the beach i mean
what about some of the big theme parks
yes the big theme parks are opening i
mean they've they've done a lot of
planning on on
social distancing um the ones outside
london
um are openings so you know alton towers
chessington
um all looking to open uh again you're
gonna have to book um and the food
offering might be slightly different
and you might see people wearing mars so
slightly different experience but i
think this is something
we're gonna have to go and try um and
it's going to be quite different
um and then the museums are opening
again it's going to be time tickets so
you might just be able to
wheel into a museum when you feel like
it i think for all attractions it's
going to be time tickets
booking online so we're going to have to
be a bit more organized
about our days out well and indeed and i
think we're all getting used to things
being a bit different aren't we
um andy tweeted me um uh sean he wanted
to know he's having problems getting a
refund for a holiday that's been
cancelled
i mean this is a common tale isn't it
that a lot of people have struggled to
get refunds and a lot of
companies especially small companies
just can't afford to give them
yeah it's it's a real shame and we've
got a lot of sympathy at active for
people who've had to wait much longer
than normal to get their money back i
mean strictly speaking
the law says if it's a package holiday
if it's cancelled by the tour operator
regardless of why
they have to give their money back
within 14 days that's just totally
impossible for the majority of them with
airlines it's an even shorter deadline
seven days
so the problem has been um for tour
operators it's simply being that they
paid the money out already they don't
keep it they pay it out to people like
airlines and hotels
and they're having to get that money
back somewhere in a very casual
position so they can give it about
themselves others are not so that's why
it's taking longer than normal but i do
know that situation has been improving
as those refunds have started to come
through and also
i know the airline civil aviation
authority is looking into certain
airlines who haven't been refunding
quickly and that would actually be
really helpful
not just to members of the public who've
booked directly with an airline but also
to tour operators who'd be waiting for
that money to come back
so they can give it back to customers so
it is an improving situation
but it still is it's very unfortunate
it's taken so long for some people i
think it's also fair to say
that some companies have done a much
better job than others but also others
they just weren't in a position to give
the money to mac if they didn't have it
because they paid it out already but i i
just
i think people have been generally very
patient but i think i fully understand
how frustrating it is particularly if
you're in financial difficulties having
to wait so long
to get that money back how many people
do you think we're talking about sean
how many people have have
been trying to get refunds over the last
few months um
what must be thousands millions millions
seriously if you look at the number of
holidays that were
it's millions so i think it's more than
that yes because if basically when
peop many people book well in advance in
january and february for their summer
holidays it's when they get the best
deals etc so
it's in their interest to do so so you
can imagine i think she's about a third
of the bookings are made in that period
so that's a lot of people
whose holidays would have been cancelled
now many chose to rebook
but others simply said no i want my
money back so i don't think it's in the
home
but there would have been a lot of
people in that position no i'd say the
majority just going on social media
that's where we get a good idea about
you know how people are feeling about
these things we've noticed recently a
distinct
dying down of people complaining about
not getting their money back
so i'd say that does imply that the
situation is improving and also
hits on our website which gives advice
on these kind of areas
certainly anything related to refunds
the hits have started to go down now
that that i think that speaks for itself
that
those refunds are coming through or have
come through but there still are
people waiting again i'd like to
apologize to them it's it's it's
a terrible situation to be in but
everybody will eventually if they wanted
to
have a refund we'll get that money back
yeah hopefully they've not gone quiet
just because they've given up
um oxana back to you um a message coming
to us on email
from jacqueline she wants to know if the
covered tests the ones that that you can
get if you think you may
have symptoms are reliable now are they
reliable
so testing is crucial for especially as
we're reopening
uh more and more currently what we
have found is that there is still about
a 20
chance of a false negative so that means
that
uh you've tested negative for the
coronavirus
but uh you are actually a carrier and of
course
um if you believe
that you are not a carrier you will
behave in very different ways
than if you get a positive result so
there is still
some work to be done to ensure the
accuracy of these tests um and
also to then follow up with the contact
tracing element
to ensure that those who are positive
do quarantine that's how you break
transmission chains
um today oxana it's been announced by
the government that lots of new
destinations
are gonna we're gonna be able to travel
to especially from england different
regulations for for the other
uh parts of the uk uh one question to us
can the virus survive in sea water if
you go on holiday and do lots of
swimming in the sea
will that protect you
there is no evidence to show that uh
this
virus can survive in in seawater so uh
i don't think that people need to be too
concerned about that
however while they're on the beach and
where when they are in water the most
important thing
remains physical and social distancing
and trying not to
um when you're speaking try to move away
from others
so more than worrying about uh sea water
which again there is no evidence just
to show that there are other really key
behaviors and
as we've seen of many popular tourist
destinations
many people are not abiding by the
physical distancing rules
okay good advice uh oksana pizzic you're
going to stay with us for the next half
but it's time now to say
goodbye and thank you to patricia yates
from visit britain to charlotte mensah
who is a hair salon owner
and it's going to be very busy tomorrow
and sean tipton from abdul thank you all
very much
uh you're watching sky news easing the
lock down special more of your questions
are going to be answered after the break
stay with us
hello you're watching an ask sky news
easing the lockdown special program i'm
joined by
a rolling panel of guests who are
answering your questions on the lockdown
changes which come into effect
in england tomorrow while still with us
is oksana pizzic from university college
london
school of pharmacy we're also though
this hour this quarter joined by maggie
appleton
who's the president of the museums
association and also the chief executive
of the raf museum
we've got kate nichols who's the chief
executive of hospitality uk
and we've also got kirsty sadler from
the restaurant chain leon
so lots of excitement about a lot of
things that you guys
represent and are offering tomorrow uh
kate to you first of all
it does seem that a trip to the pub is
was what is exciting most
people talk us through what a trip to
the pub will be like
tomorrow compared to how it used to be
well i think you're going to see a lot
less informality a lot less spontaneity
there is going to be a greater degree of
pre-booking
people are reserving tables and it's
clearly popular
activity to do so people are reserving
tables not just for when they're eating
but also when they're having a drink in
the pub in the afternoon and the evening
what you're going to see first and
foremost is that it's fully seated
inside
there'll be no standing at the bar and
drinking at the bar but hopefully you
will still retain the atmosphere
of a great british pub and have the full
experience of great british hospitality
with more
at table service more online ordering
where it's appropriate
uh but also more seating and more food
and i suppose outdoor seating is going
to be at a premium isn't it
a lot are you more likely to be sitting
outdoors these days than you ever would
be it might be a good idea to take your
coat knowing the good british summer
well i think that is the limitation
isn't it with our great british weather
but yes um an encouragement for people
to be out of doors
uh an ability when you're at the pub to
be able to meet
six people from different households if
you're out of doors
indoors it's just going to be members of
two different households that will be
coming together to eat and drink
so in the pub if you're wanting to meet
up with friends it's going to be an
outdoor activity
and obviously from the end of this month
we will see a greater increase in the
areas outside
pubs and bars and restaurants with
deregulation of pavement licenses and
service
in gardens so yes it will be more of an
outdoor activity
there'll be more space to be able to to
go and eat and drink outdoors
and more opportunities to enjoy our
hospitality and is it safe for you to
take elderly relatives
to the pub not that they'll be the ones
escorting you home
well obviously that is for people to
make their own decisions about the level
of risk that they feel comfortable
making
we would recommend that for older
customers that they want to make sure
that they can be seated
and that they therefore book in advance
and reserve a table in advance
but clearly outside is less risky than
indoors
and we'll have put in place all the
measures that we need to do to make sure
social distancing is maintained with
inside our premises
and hygiene and sanitation standards are
as high as
they possibly can be but clearly it is
going to be a decision for customers to
take
about their level of risk we can
guarantee that when they come there
we'll be safe
it's for them to make that decision uh
and kirsty just a bit more on
on the hospitality and on food um how
our
restaurant chains like likely on
ensuring that food is prepared
in a covert friendly way
yeah i mean i think you know we're in
the business always of dealing with food
which needs to have really high safety
around it a lot of hygiene so
obviously we've just taken like that all
a step further
um so there's been um much more effort
into
team training and reminders and alarms
being set
we're now looking at hand washing every
15 minutes um we're in a slightly
different situation as the nature of
being a naturally fast food business
where actually
more of what we look at is just um fewer
team members really coming into contact
with any individual meal
which obviously helps reduce risk it's
slightly different on
restaurants or from scratch fully from
scratch
system but it is just trying to keep the
focus of the team members
lots of checks in place and also just
trying to make sure that that is still
happening when actually we've got a lot
of reduced
team members in a kitchen space kitchens
that might normally have about 18
members we're now due to distancing
we're looking at having about three
wow so that's that's a real reduction in
staff isn't it and will
will all of those staff be wearing face
masks when they're in the kitchens
yes we have a full supply of face masks
and of gloves and so there's both
their own protection when they're
starting their shift and then obviously
all of those training and checks and
balances
in place so not just about their own
hand washing it's about continuing to
clean
surfaces as well so for example outside
of front of house
we have lots of things in place that are
giving flexibility for customers to come
in and order in a way they feel
comfortable
so just for example we have kiosks and
then being wiped down again
with a real frequency so there's a quite
a lot of kit for the team
and just yeah it's a lot of it is about
the procedures
let's bring oksana our resident expert
back in and
alexander we obviously we've heard from
from pubs and restaurants and they are
all taking these precautions but
not all shops not all supermarkets not
all of the staff and those places are
are wearing face coverings should they
be and does that make a difference to
the spread
well the w show has made clear that face
masks are not a silver bullet
it's one tool in a comprehensive public
health package so
the distancing in addition to face masks
can make a difference
some supermarkets are actually offering
face masks to individuals
upon entry not all but some and also
more and more we see people uh having
their creating their own face coverings
uh particularly if they do have um
other types of uh issues to that the
underlying conditions etc
so from the perspective of uh the face
mask in itself
there's still the the markers that are
laid down on the floor to ensure
uh that people are keeping their
distance that these cues are in order
many places also have a plexi glass type
dividers as well um and not only face
masks we also see
that visors are also being
face shields are being used and even at
ucl we have colleagues who are 3d
printing these
uh for those that are in uh public
facing roles
uh such as in in shops or in pharmacies
so face masks are a good idea and the w
show does recommend
that if it is not possible uh to keep a
one
meter distance and physical distance
from others uh that it is uh recommended
to wear them
but in itself it is not a uh be all
solution
uh maggie let's bring you in now um of
talk about museums the president of the
museum's association
how are museums going to be different is
it is it going to be very similar to
what we've just heard
uh timed entrances etc etc
very similar principles yes so timed
entrances
and it's worth remembering that every
museum is different different localities
different shapes and sizes but we're all
working to the same principles and
those principles are all about the
public feeling
safe and it's that combination of really
helping the public to feel safe coming
back to our wonderful
museums and while still being able to
give a really warm welcome
so it's our own museum at the royal air
force museum we have two sites one in
the west midlands and one in north
london
and yes a pre-booked entry so we're
asking everyone to book before they come
we're opening both our sites on monday
and it's worth saying that some museums
won't be opening for some time
partly because of their spaces partly
because they can't afford to so we've
all been going through a real tricky
time
as as i think the nations are we're
across cultural organizations
we open on monday pre-booked we've got a
great in-flight
um video to share with visitors what
they'll expect when they come in and
what they can hope to see
so we're having one-way systems we can
keep a two meter distance at our sites
because we've got big hangers and
beautiful outdoor spaces
um and uh very much encouraging
um visitors to use that space so we'll
be keeping visitors
apart but i hope with a real warm
welcome our staff are wearing visors so
we can still
give them a big smile when they come in
how hard are the last few months been
you talked about some places not
reopening
um obviously some museums have got
central funding
you know a lot of museums are free but
but smaller museums especially
how many do you think won't reopen
well we hope the most will reopen it
will be a phased re-opening though and
when they can
afford to and again it varies so much so
the the
museums are it uh really having a
difficult time immediately
of course with those that have charged
for entry and have lost their income
over the last
uh three months it's just disappeared
but of course local authority
museums many of which are free are also
being concerned that it's really going
to hit them
over the next perhaps year two years
three years so
every museum is affected but in very
different ways and
the rf museum's the same we've lost
about one and a half million pounds from
being closed for three months so
we are asking our visitors and
supporters
to keep on supporting and donating us
donating to us to do the incredible work
that we do
and that all museums across the uk um
are doing it's part of our really
important cultural landscape that's um
really important there to keep uh you
know the morale
um alive but also helping us reflect uh
on
our current situation in the world so
museums are important and
we're all working really hard to be able
to reopen our doors
and welcome people back kate nicholls
um social distancing in a museum uh as
as we've heard you know in this instance
a big museum with open space is
quite easy social distancing and alcohol
though do you think they mix and do you
think pubs are going to become
the pinch point are they going to have
extra door staff for example
well obviously hospitality is a broad
and diverse industry so it's not just
about the the pubs that are reopening
we have big spaces in our restaurants
our hotels as many of our bars
where social distancing can be managed
carefully and we put in place systems
and processes and training
to be able to ensure that our staff are
able to make sure that people do
socialize safely and responsibly the
principal mechanism we're using in pubs
everybody is going to be seated indoors
so those seats are fixed we can make
sure customers are keeping a responsible
distance
and you're not having people standing up
where social distancing might be a bit
more fluid
and just as kirsty said our businesses
are very well versed in managing risky
situations and risky substances
day in day out when they're cooking food
when they're serving alcohol
they are twice licensed both the
individual serving it and the premises
that uh is is hosting the social event
so
they are licensed individuals licensed
premises responsible and capable of
managing the risks within their premises
so that we can all keep ourselves safe
so people need to be aware that there'll
be a warm welcome but it'll be a safe
and responsible one
and and we talked about the museums
about the possibility of people
supporting them financially
they'll be hoping people will donate
more pubs and restaurants have really
financially suffered is there going to
be for example
minimum spends are prices going to be a
lot higher when people do go in the next
few weeks
now what we're doing first and foremost
is trying to restore consumer confidence
to encourage our people to come back
our customers to come back and have a
good time with us we know we need
to make sure that they feel comfortable
to do that confident to do that
and the spend will return the government
needs to work with us to make sure that
customers do get that message
that they can enjoy summer safely and
responsibly um but the industry has
suffered
massively it's been the the hardest hit
industry of any sector
with when it comes to covid we've lost
73 billion pounds worth of revenue many
of our businesses
have struggled to reopen this year
altogether
and therefore we need continued
government support as well as support
from our customers
but we won't be looking to to profit out
of this we'll be making sure that people
have a warm welcome
and are encouraged to come back you've
been nodding away there
at the end there kirsty from leon during
that
um so so you're not gonna put your
prices up but you do need to get bums on
seats you need to get people
in and out as quickly as possible don't
you are you gonna put
time limits on the slots that people can
can dine in the restaurants
yeah again i mean it is just so case by
case it depends on your business
and what's going to be the most
appealing way to get people back in and
also the safest way for you to manage
it um for us at leon we are opening
tomorrow
and inviting people to be able to come
and eat in um
we've actually been lucky that again
because we've got flexibility we can
we've been able to actually stay open
throughout the entire crisis
largely of course during um the worst
phase of it
for uh click and collect and take away
delivery
in terms of eating um we're obviously
focusing on opening the sites that have
got more space
um so that people feel more comfortable
and can stay two meters apart
we're actually not uh going to put
restrictions on it we've just
on our sign posting we've asked people
kind of consider
themselves and the people who might be
passing or waiting to come in
um but i think also for quite a lot of
people this is just an opportunity to go
and occupy a different space
uh you know somewhere other than their
four walls so you know in a weekday
where we maybe are quieter and there
isn't such a demand for the seating
um we don't want people to feel rushed
um so it's going to be a balance and
obviously we're opening with about five
restaurants tomorrow to allow and invite
people back in
and we're going to see how that goes um
and i think each restaurant and their
team as well are going to be different
and we're going to just have to gauge
what's necessary to keep the team happy
and comfortable and to keep customers
like kate said feeling welcome because
the team are incredibly excited
and to have more people coming back in i
mean that's why a lot of them are in the
hospitality industry so
there's something to look forward to for
us maggie just briefly to you
are you concerned about enforcing social
distancing because people are coming for
a day out to enjoy themselves they don't
want to be told off
um are you going to be physically for
enforcing it if people breach it
i think um museums as we've been talking
about with
other colleagues we're all about the
warm welcome and certainly museums that
have opened internationally already
and colleagues that have opened in parks
and seas so far
are all saying that actually visitors
are so pleased to be back
um so we're not expecting to have to
enforce it we have got more
of the team on to help with the social
distancing but it is all about
supporting our visitors and welcoming
them so yeah
very much about the warm welcome uh
axana just a final one to you as well
before we lose you and
the one person's written in uh jill's
written in to say could reopening
schools
result in a second peak uh that has been
a concern over
the last few days obviously it's not
going to happen until september
but are you concerned as an
epidemiologist about that
certainly i think we can all agree that
we do need to ensure that children
are getting their education and that we
close
the education gap that's widening the
government needs to be planning
very closely with schools at this stage
use this summer period to create a
variety of
different plans so that to ensure that
each school
is safe because this is obviously going
to be
very difficult and could could
realistically shift that reproduction
number
um above one quite quickly as
quickly as december um so the potential
for that
is very high however there has been many
discussions around
uh how to reduce contact how to keep
classes in bubbles so that they don't
interact
with other students outside of that
particular classroom and whether that
goes ahead or not
we will see but it is vital that in
order for us to reopen our society and
for
kids to get back to school that we
improve
the testing and tracing system so that
we can quickly nip those uh outbreaks as
they incur in schools
but in regions like we saw in leicester
alexander pizzic
good to talk to you thanks for joining
us and giving us your expertise today
also
uh this quarter maggie appleton the
woman the biggest smile uh
from museums uh kate nichols chief
executive hospitality uk
and kirsty sadler from leon thank you
all very much for joining us to talk
about
how all of your organizations are going
to cope we're going to be talking health
next and police you're watching the sky
news easing
lockdown special more of your questions
are coming up we're also going to be
hearing from the prime minister
at five o'clock so stay tuned for that
[Music]
you're watching the sky news easing the
lockdown special program i'm joined by
a rolling panel of guests who are
answering your questions on the lockdown
changes which come into effect
in england from tomorrow and joining me
for this part dr richard valtry who's
the chair of the british
medical association's gp committee henna
anwar who's an nhs doctor
and katie born the association of police
and crime commissioners
uh joins us also thank you all very much
um uh
to you first um dr richard
um how likely do you fear a second wave
is
as a result of everything opening up
tomorrow
there is a real prospect of a second
wave particularly if people
are not social distancing so it's
imperative as people do start to mix
more
with others and that they do keep their
distance uh that they do wash their
hands well
um that they wear face masks if they
have to go closer to people
than two meters or in confined spaces
it's imperative that we all
do our best to avoid this virus from
spiking back up again
and causing a further lockdown uh of
course not everything's opening tomorrow
paul has emailed and he wants to know
when when do you think it'll be safe for
councils to open
day care centers for adults with severe
autism and i suppose there are lots of
other conditions
that people will be keen to get help
with that provide adult day care
any idea when you think it might be a
sensible time for those to be reopening
i think it's very difficult and i think
it's dependent on
the the checks and balances for each
individual facility
we know that some people are much more
vulnerable than others but also that
it's more complicated
for certain establishments to open up
and to ensure appropriate safe
and social distancing in place so it is
something that we will be
watching the government's guidance very
carefully
another tweet this time wendy has been
in touch
she says should the elderly continue to
self-isolate even though the government
said it is safe
for them to go out i think it's
important that we recognize there's a
balance between
uh social isolation so you know the
benefit of
reducing your risk from the virus but
also the problem
of your mental health being impacted by
a prolonged
absence from company of others so taking
sensible precautions for everybody is
imperative
the government has issued advice for all
people regardless of age
um around social distancing that should
be imperative at all times
but we do need to recognize that we all
benefit from company of other people
and that can help us through these
really difficult times
let's bring in katie bourne to talk
about about the police i mean a lot of
people are obviously celebrating
that the pubs are open tomorrow but but
i wonder how the police community is
feeling about tomorrow
um how are they feeling about enforcing
the one meter plus rule
and how difficult it will be for them if
people ignore it
well first of all um you know we
understand why people are very excited
about tomorrow of course we put up with
nearly 100 days of
being in lockdown and and the police all
along
have been very clear that they are not
there to police social distance they
won't be holding up tape measures to
people
to ensure that they're staying two
meters or at least one meter apart
that's not their role their role has
always been to support public health
around this so this is about engaging
with people
explaining why we have social distancing
encouraging them to
to take responsibility and then only
using enforcement as a last resort so
police forces up and down the country
are getting ready for tomorrow will they
be hoping that that it will be
pubs restaurants shops that will it
will be encouraging people to follow the
rules
rather than them having to actually step
in and and actually enforce it
i think that you're absolutely right
that is exactly what we are hoping
people will do that they will take
responsibility themselves
and we're in this collective endeavor
together this
is not about the police coming in and
telling people what they can and they
can't do
at the end of the day we all have a
responsibility we make decisions about
risk every day of our lives
you know we decide when we cross the
road we decide whether we fly in
airplanes and so on
but this isn't just about the risk to
ourselves we must understand that we are
still in the middle of a pandemic
and we don't have a pure vaccine for
this virus yet
so we have a responsibility to keep
ourselves safe but also
think about others around us as well
which is why we have these guidelines in
place
how busy do you think it's going to be
tomorrow of our forces
bringing in extra staff and and people
from holiday
forces are gearing up they're ready for
this as you can expect they've had plans
in place for some time
i'm certainly in my own force area in
sussex you know we have over 100 miles
of coastline
we have the big city brighton hove and
we do expect people to
to come and to enjoy themselves you know
the pubs the clubs are open
we're going back to some sort of
normality but of course
at the end of the day you would expect
to be ready and out there but again you
know we are asking people to be really
sensitive about this
social distancing is not a nice to have
it's there to protect all of us it's
there to save lives
and that's ultimately what we need to
remember okay
let's bring in our a and e dr henna
anwar um
i imagine you're also gearing up for
tomorrow it's been really quiet in a lot
of a eat hasn't it over the last few
months
aside from covid what are your feelings
about tomorrow
yes sorry so i don't um
i don't work in a e all the time i'm a
gp registrar that sometimes does shifts
in a
e um and so i can't i feel like i can't
comment
on um how busy our quiet a a department
has been
um but what i can say about the feelings
um about
the hospitality sector opening up is it
it doesn't
it doesn't matter how me or any other
healthcare professional actually feels
about it
we know that it's happening and we just
want everything to happen safely
um and that's all all the rules and the
guidelines that people have been talking
about before me
um and just like my colleague has said
to remember to do things like washing
their hands regularly
and that's to protect you and to protect
anybody else that's coming into contact
with this virus
and we we know the risk of transmission
um
is also higher indoors so as people
start you know visiting
houses just to be aware of that and to
be aware that the social
distance guides are still there um
and we do still need to self-isolate if
we get
symptoms you know those rules haven't
changed
and we do still need to be really
careful about visiting
um as we start to be allowed to be
visiting people's houses
that we're careful about who we're
visiting and if we have symptoms
and you know somebody has been shielding
um
you know that they've got a higher risk
of getting the virus just to be careful
about visiting them and don't go if
you've got any symptoms
and things like that so um i think you
know
i i
[Music]
have spoken to my colleagues in a a and
i wouldn't say that it's quiet you know
we've been busy
and we've been they've been split into
separate areas so
they've been seeing the covered patients
in one area and then the other patients
in the other area
um it's been busy and everybody's been
doing the best job that they can do
i know uh casey from the police that
that just seeing the police around
it's obviously not been simple for the
police to social distance themselves has
it
they often work as a as a pair um henna
how
how easy or hard is it for you to social
distance
in your job itself when when there's
somebody in a critical condition or when
you have to get close to a patient
to see what's wrong with them
yeah so um so we have to maintain
uh the guidance that we've been given
um and we know we have to wear personal
protective equipment when we're seeing
patients and and that's in the hospital
and
within the gp sector um so
with within uh the general practice
patients uh are seen in separate areas
um
so we have coverage sites and then we
have other sites that are not covered
sites
um so so we we do have um strict rules
in place that to ensure the safety of
ourselves as well as the safety of the
patients
let's bring in dr richard again from the
bma from bma's gp committee
and there's been real differences in
social distancing i've noticed just
walking around
some people wearing masks keeping their
distance other people
and not going to generalize but but
often young people
um not doing it quite so much is that to
do with
um was it just spatial awareness uh
so it does seem that some people just
don't really realize when they're
getting close to other people
so that was one one point but but the
broader point was
if enough people do do it properly
will it help everybody else
yes i mean there's increasing evidence
that wearing masks protects those around
you
and the more of us that do wear masks we
will reduce the spread of infection
particularly if we're not able to
maintain
a greater than two meter distance
between one another so if you are
in close proximity uh by wearing a mask
you're protecting those around you they
will protect you by wearing a mask you
know and i think it is important
we start to recognize that this is
what's happening around the world
and increasingly we should be doing it
here in the uk
and i've got a couple of final questions
for you all i'll come to you first henna
and
do you feel attitudes have changed
towards the nhs as
a result of covert 19.
um yes about i mean that's a very good
question and
so in in my personal experience i feel
that
people in the uk have always felt proud
of the nhs
but certainly over the last few months
they may have been more vocal about the
support that they've shown
and i've always felt privileged to be
part of this healthcare system here in
the uk and
honestly for me and my colleagues i feel
the support has actually helped us get
through this really difficult time
um but but coming into this weekend we
know that it's the 72nd birthday of the
nhs
and and i just want to point out that as
we come out of this lockdown
for me this this birthday feels
different this year we'll remember all
the people that we've lost our patients
and all our colleagues
um and it's just be to be mindful of
that and i've i've
seen just how hard everybody's been
working um
and i'm sure that's with them support
from the the public has actually helped
that
good point henna and katie bourne i mean
i suppose in the same vein
you like many people will be presumably
excited that that
new things are happening tomorrow but
are you also looking towards tomorrow
with a bit of apprehension
well i you know i've been lying if i
said i wasn't because
obviously you want everything to to work
well and you don't want to see
areas um becoming unsafe but at the end
of the day you know the majority of the
public throughout lockdown have behaved
brilliantly
we are talking about minorities
and i was just reflecting actually on
the question you
you said to henno before i think we're
all incredibly
grateful and proud of our nhs staff but
let's not forget all the emergency
service workers
and actually all those workers on the
front line you know that
we all took for granted before but
actually now we realize the value of the
jobs that they do for us
so i think with that in mind tomorrow
let's say let's bear that in mind when
we're behaving responsibly let's go and
raise a glass let's have fun by all
means
you know drink responsibly be careful
and don't forget that the pandemic is
still amongst us the virus is still here
and until we have a vaccine it's our
duty to look after ourselves and those
around us
well that's a very sane point and it
seems like a good one to end on
katie bourne from the association of
police and crime commissioners henna
anwar
an nhs doctor and dr richard vaultry a
bit from the bma's gp committee thank
you all very very much for joining us
today